[Music]
alright hey guys
week two of this here thought the last
episode is going to be the second
episode last episode was the first
episode which means there's a there's a
ghost episode out there that you'll
never hear but whatever
maybe I'll maybe I'll maybe I'll make it
come out at some point you know like a
cut it together and do a little best of
if this hits you know a hundred episodes
or something like that but let's not
make our goals too lofty and just what's
up welcome to congratulations and I'm
Chris D'Elia and I'm here and dude this
is like this is like pretty good for me
because oh by the way it's echoey a
little bit and we're going to take care
of that next week I know it's a little
echoey but I got a bunch of I'm getting
these 24 I'm getting 24 these [ __ ]
head great like sound things and I'm
going to hang them up and so that'll
take care of that I think and if that
doesn't work then I'm just going to
cover myself in blankets and do it under
it like like I'm 4 years old and I built
a tent in my house with him and with a
flashlight and that'll take care of it
but yeah so that's what's up I am back
in town I was I was in Minneapolis and
also Indianapolis and also Chicago and I
am still prepping from an hour that I'm
going to shoot in Vancouver on the 24th
I think and so it's going well I did one
show in Minneapolis at a college which
was cool it was kind of like a [ __ ]
cafeteria when you get to these college
gigs
uh you never know what kind of room
you're going to end up playing is
sometimes you literally are playing in a
library and people are trying to read as
well and study which by the way don't
have a library anymore because also
there's the Internet but these colleges
have libraries and sometimes you're
performing in the cafeterias and [ __ ] or
in the science room and but no it was
pretty good the class came the school
came out it was awesome college guys got
to get their lighting right though you
know whenever I get to a college gig
it's like some like you know nervous 19
year old that's like oh thanks for
coming we you know we booked we really
wanted to book in and you're here now
and so if there's anything you need let
us know and I would say something like
very easy I'll be like oh yeah well
maybe a coffee and I'll be like oh okay
um oh okay well let me follow me um okay
yeah that's what the quote is that and
then I'll build and then I'll wait and
then he'll leave for a while come back
with no coffee never mention the coffee
and then and then the show will start
and it's fine because he's a kid and I
don't want to [ __ ] with them and be like
what the [ __ ] my coffee cuz I'm not a
diva I don't give a [ __ ] really that
much it just he offered so whatever but
that happens all the time and so um so
anyway you get out there and then I'm
like can you just make it as dark as
possible you got to tell these guys to
do it as dark as possible because if not
you'll get out there and it'll be like
oh this isn't a show all 1000 of us are
getting abducted because that's what it
feels like because the [ __ ] light is
so bright out there because they don't
know how to run a show which why would
they they're you know they just are in
charge of the entertainment [ __ ] that
they then they're 19 they don't have a
[ __ ] set up a show which is I don't I
don't blame them so you get out there
and you're and and and and they did they
made it as dark as possible but they can
never make it as dark as possible
because there's always emergency lights
on because it's a college and they need
to have like safety rules and [ __ ] so I
was out there doing a show and it was
like pitch black for the front half and
the back half there were like five
hundred kids in this [ __ ] bright
light that was like this safety light
and so I was doing crowd work to the K
in the [ __ ] back which I've never
done before because usually you just do
crowd work to the people up front but
anyway that show was great
then I did an Indian as shown
Indianapolis which was awesome
a theater there who know the Egyptian
room and Indianapolis came out man it
was awesome
and then I did Chicago for two shows at
the Vic which is maybe arguably my
favorite theater in America that I've
done I wanted to shoot my special there
but it was just everyone shoots their
special there so I'm doing it in
Vancouver uh and I'm ready I'll be in
Atlanta this the end of this week but or
maybe up maybe last week I don't know in
this podcast coming out
but anyway it's cold as [ __ ] dude it's
cold as [ __ ] everywhere but but like it
feels like LA like I get to these places
and it's like yeah we're you're in
Minneapolis and it's it's literally 12
degrees it's 12 [ __ ] degrees and it's
February which is fine I know that's the
cold month but like and I get people
grow up there and they get used to it
and [ __ ] like that but I can't imagine
living in a place that's [ __ ] that
gets twelve degrees
the second la got twelve degrees I'm out
dude
I'm out dude you don't understand I
blast my heat in my hotel room no matter
what the [ __ ] temperature it is because
it's always cold in hotel rooms I'm like
a girl and how girls always cold
you know when girls when like you're
like when you're starting to hang out
with a girl and like you're like ah
she's awesome and you're and then and
then like you're watching TV one night
you get to the point where you're just
like lounging and then she just cuddles
up on you and then her hand feels like a
[ __ ] penguin like it's so cold
that's how cold I am always and I always
make my hotel room
eighty [ __ ] degrees and any time I
open her comes in they're like aw come
on I'm like this is how it is you
[ __ ] work for me you sit here and you
hang out and we lose some weight but um
so so yeah it's free I don't understand
this I don't understand I don't
understand being in a place that's
called I love Chicago but man [ __ ] that
dude
be in LA only you know what I mean and
don't even be in Miami either because
Miami is always warm but [ __ ] those 30
minutes torrential downpours you'll be
hanging out at like you you like go to a
[ __ ] Radio Shack to get some [ __ ]
and then you come at a Radio Shack and
there's cars flying by like in the air
because it's like a scene from twister
because image and you got to just wait
inside the radio shack for 30 minutes
like yeah the cars will stop [ __ ]
flying around because it's just these
storms last 23 minutes [ __ ] that all you
live in a pole you live in a place where
it'll it'll torrential e down rain will
torrential e down for fall downpour what
you know I'm trying to say oh for 23
minutes ah nah oh dude oh dude really
quick I won't live there you're really
quick oh I live in a place that doesn't
have that because there are places like
that in the world so live those places
oh but your family grew up oh you by
your family grew up you grew up there
and your family's there I'll move them
Oh your family's staying there
oh go somewhere else I know I know
that's a little bit of a like harsh
stance but [ __ ] that um I went to Miami
though once I did a show and I didn't
know it was going to let land on
I think it's called ultra the [ __ ]
EDM festival
first of all Miami don't have a festival
because you're Miami Indianapolis have a
festival because people don't have
anything to do they're really sorry I
mean I'm not really that sorry saying
that but like Miami having a festival is
like is like doing cocaine on cocaine
like you can do some cocaine and then
you're at the top of your [ __ ] and then
you're like let's do more cocaine like
you're good just chill don't do that
don't do more right Miami a festival in
Miami is like that one person who is
like just way too drunk and
the night like there's [ __ ] four or
five guys and you're out having a good
time and everyone's like this drunk and
they're like yellow man [ __ ] so fun
dude do you remember when Tommy did this
[ __ ] and he [ __ ] did that and I was so
funny his dad came in a room that's fine
that's Miami but then there's the other
guy that's like yo dude you foggy you
know the fog dude you trying to talk
this [ __ ] man [ __ ] that guy and he's
pointed a guy over there and he's like
[ __ ] man you see the way you forget
bumped into this [ __ ] and that's what
Miami and a festival is it's not fun
dudes with shirts off and so many
tattoos by the way the dudes are short
as [ __ ] and buff with pink board shorts
on by I got pink board shorts on your
for six and you're whiter than you are
tall by ultra dude ultra it's called
ultra they literally were like we're
gonna have a festival I met in Miami
what should we call it and before they
got to the word it they're like what
should we call an eight and some guy
goes like this ultra obviously Oh a
festival in my ultra some guy goes ultra
because that's the most
Namie name there is and they'll be like
what if there's a torrential down fall
down pour what have my downpour what if
there's a torrential downpour over 23
minutes and they'd be like [ __ ] it do it
it's ultra beanie on tenyo tenyo TM TM
TM TM TM TM TM TM TM TM TM TM -
sunglasses on doesn't matter is it
nighttime doesn't matter sunglasses on
hey dude do you have your sunglasses no
can't get an ultra then why cuz it's
ultra denim denim denim tintin tintin
tintin until the rains come in who cares
leave your sunglasses on all right fine
it's now you're gonna hit me for a long
time anyway I'm for six 10 in 10 10 10
10 10 10 10 10 10 10 mm - I'm drowning
because I'm too short it's all good just
stand on me now both of us together are
6 5 10 M 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 10 M 10 on
10 I don't own that song until May that
song plays until May that's how long the
song is that's how long the song is
it plays until May I don't give a [ __ ]
what month it is plays until May if it's
May it plays until next May 10 in 10
a.m. 10 a.m. to noon til so that's Miami
and I can't even do it I did a show in
Miami I did two shows in Miami and one
time and I was like I'm just gonna play
Fort Lauderdale from now on I'm not
ultra I am NOT ultra um so yeah so we
did the shows in Chicago and it was fun
had some good openers there and now I'm
back in LA and I caught the end of the
the Super Bowl which was I'm not a
football guy by any means I'm not a
sports guy if you know anything about me
you know that I can't get into something
I can't get into something that where
there are teams it's just that's I'm not
into teams like if I can lose a game and
blame it on someone else then it's their
fault it doesn't make me feel like I'm
like are you [ __ ] up bro if I'm the
tight end or whatever the [ __ ] or you
know and then we lose I could be like
yeah it was a quarterbacks fault
you know but if I'm if I'm doing a like
that's why like bowling is cool because
it's just you but also but also it's not
cool but it is because it's just you
like like like MMA is cool it's just you
I mean even though you got the coach and
that's important I understand that or
the train or whatever the [ __ ]
but yeah I just can't get in a team
sport cuz who cares because it's
everyone else's fault if we lose that's
that's how my ego works but I said I
watched the end of it and Patriots came
back and they won and um Joe Buck is
incredible though Joe Buck is incredible
I am a big Joe Buck fan and it's because
I feel like I don't know this because I
don't know anything about sports but I
feel like people did totally don't like
Joe Buck
I feel like people are so angry I feel
like if I feel like Joe Buck has the job
and he and he has the job but he
wouldn't have won the popular vote to
get the job that's how I feel like Joe
Buck is and everyone is like [ __ ] this
no we don't like Joe Buck but he's still
there because like the people in charge
voted for him and he's just like I feel
like Joe Buck will be like now that's
some football and you're like oh yeah
cuz the plan football but he and he's
got that show too undeniable it's called
I think on the audience Channel and I
leave it on because got the balls you
have to have to call your show
undeniable the the [ __ ] balls that's
that's actually you know what that's the
[ __ ] that's what the Festival in
Miami should be called undeniable and
Joe Buck should be out there and he'll
be like now that's a rave um but yeah
he's got a boat with it's like an
intimate thing I don't know why
everybody wants everybody to get
intimate what the [ __ ] is that dude what
the [ __ ] is that why does everybody want
everybody else to get intimate and then
be like I was great episode no matter
what the [ __ ] the guy does everyone
wants them to get intimate
Joe Buck has a [ __ ] football player
on there and and he's crying because
there's something that happened in his
childhood his dad took the ball away or
something
and that's what made him a football
player the last thing I want to watch is
Dennis Rodman crying I don't want to
watch Dennis Rodman crying I don't give
a [ __ ] about that I want to watch Dennis
Rodman talking about North Korea that's
what I want to watch about remember when
that [ __ ] happened and he was talking
all about how he was like he we played
in North Korea and everyone was so mad
dude I don't give a [ __ ] about what the
[ __ ] they got the manager of the Dallas
Cowboys talking about and then when I
was 11 oh I don't give a [ __ ] I don't
care when you were 11 I don't care dude
I swear to God were a second away from
having a show that gets the guy from
Cake Boss on it talking about what
happened when he was 14 and that's why
he makes cakes why does everyone want to
get ever
everyone wants everyone else to get
intimate [ __ ] that I'm down for a silly
goose time and that's it everybody talks
about comedians oh it's great he got
personal I guess so
I guess so I mean the best comedians can
be personal but still be funny but who
gives his [ __ ] why what is it about that
I don't know what it is it's so crazy to
me it's so crazy to me I don't know some
of the best funniest shows are not like
like Always Sunny in Philadelphia isn't
like that it's [ __ ] hilarious I loved
it people love that [ __ ] man inside who
you are I guess relate relatability I
guess I don't know we're all [ __ ] up I
guess that's how it makes us feel kid
good it's okay I can be [ __ ] up if the
guy from Cake Boss is up here crying an
undeniable undeniable
everybody wants somebody to be but
anyway so the Patriots came back which
was crazy man I want I wanted Atlanta to
win just because I don't give a [ __ ] I
you know what I want whatever team has
the ball to win that's what I want
because I want some good down-to-earth
Smash Mouth football I don't know what
that means but that's what I want her to
guys say her Joe Buck said um and but my
favorite thing about my least favorite
here's what I here's what I don't like
about here's what I [ __ ] can't stand
about football and and this is what
there's a lot of there's a lot of sports
that do this and I'm done with this [ __ ]
you play four quarters and then the team
with the higher score wins then
if it's a tie you have to play more
which is not okay you decide who wins at
the end of the game no matter what in my
world that's how it goes if I was the
[ __ ] Commissioner of football or
whatever that guy is up there that I go
like this it's over and they say but
it's a tie I say then we look who played
better and that's it if the game is as
long as the game then that's it
you don't [ __ ] tie and then say well
okay but okay well let's just play a
little bit longer then that's not how
long the game is baseball goes into
extra innings
no you look at the [ __ ] whoever got
more hits then oh whoa okay the game is
over well we'll keep playing until
someone else's course then why don't you
just play until someone scores start the
game play until someone scores that's
the one of the game was 14 seconds
that's it you telling me you don't know
how long the game's gonna be I'm gonna
play indefinitely that's basically what
you're saying no [ __ ] that I got [ __ ] to
do [ __ ] that I'm going to sit down and
watch a 4-hour game and then if it's not
over I'm gonna watch more eat my dick
straight up here's what I hate even more
than football soccer so okay so the
[ __ ] game is for quarters you son of
a [ __ ] and then it's 3 to 3 which by
the way is too low of a score add more
goals make them on the sides or some
[ __ ] have a guy have [ __ ] Romano
Fellini kick a [ __ ] a [ __ ] goal to
the side of it and be like hey but that
that side of the good you know I gotta
go for the side 1 Romano Fellini is
gonna [ __ ] kick past Alfonso conch
Enzo and he's gonna [ __ ] score
there's seven goals that's the new game
there's seven goals and the end of the
game is going to be [ __ ] 127 to 114
n either the Italians or the [ __ ] but
I sealians are going to win and that's
it and if it's tied the game is over
you look at the team who had the list
least fouls or maybe the lease errors or
whatever the [ __ ] who if Alfonso Fellini
is injured then the [ __ ] Paris aliens
win ok but oh you're gonna [ __ ] stop
the game when it's tied 2-2 to eat my
dick and then abandon the game and just
have a shootout oh hey the game's over
now let's just kick and try and score
goals are you [ __ ] kidding me dude
that is actually so disrespectful to
hockey era to walkie does it to to
[ __ ] soccer fans no dude alright hey
do alright the game is over dude we
tried it's one to one
or better yet it's zero two zero zero
pull my eyeballs out if it's zero to
zero dude pull my eyeballs out if it's
zero to zero and I watched a game for 14
hours because they're way too long and
now have the goalie just stand here by
the way goalie as if it's not
disrespectful enough put these [ __ ]
big-ass Mickey Mouse gloves on and guard
your little Italian [ __ ] balls dude
that's so disrespectful hey hey guy from
Brazil we're gonna have [ __ ] five
Italians rock it a multicolored soccer
ball into your [ __ ] Brazilian dick
and balls so put on these Mickey Mouse
gloves and guard your five inch [ __ ]
dude that's that's the new game that's
the new game they basically say [ __ ]
soccer guard your balls we're gonna have
five Italians rocket hey guy from
Nigeria guard your 12 inch [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] man while [ __ ] seven guys
from Croatia rut rocket no dude no
that's the game then then that's the
game that's the game then shootout
that's what you call it you call the
game shootout god I [ __ ] hate that oh
we're gonna be I'm what dude if I was a
Martian and I came to earth and I
watched soccer and then the game's over
and I was like well that was a gun game
and then somebody who was here was like
no well you got a-you got it we got to
keep going like one do you mean like
ain't you said the game would be for
quarters they're like well but it's tied
one is this tie look at how many
injuries there are or how many good you
know how many attempts or assists or
whatever the [ __ ] and then they say oh
no we're just going to do a shootout and
I say but that's a different game [ __ ]
that you're take me into your leaner and
then I get to the leader oh shrink him
down and then leave I'm not doing that
[ __ ] man that's [ __ ] dude that's so
[ __ ] up dude for real I think that's
[ __ ] up change the game so yeah so
that's what that's what happened dude
and that was the first like whatever
they call it a fifth quarter sudden
death in in Super Bowl history 52 years
or whatever that's crazy that was a hard
stat to believe um so yeah that's what
happened um and that's my rules on
sports I think uh so I flew back from uh
I flew back from Chicago I used to hate
flying actually and now I love it
because you can just zone out you
literally can't do anything and you just
have to sit there and watch like keeping
up with the Joneses or whatever the [ __ ]
not not whatever that does some move you
got to watch a movie you have to if
you're lucky enough to get one of the
planes and by the way it's [ __ ] that
you can pay for a flight and you don't
know if you're going to get a plane
that's new or from 1967 you
it's like oh yeah okay yeah you know if
you're on first class you pay a [ __ ]
shitload of money and you might get a
pod with a curtain and a [ __ ] like
unlimited hot cocoa and a [ __ ] like a
lady that a literally be on call to suck
your dick or a plane from 1967 that
reclines an inch and a half and you have
to hold a chicken you know what I mean
be like oh it's just part of it sorry we
need to transport these chickens and
you're like I'll go [ __ ] yourself I paid
$4,000 for this give me the plane from
2000 and [ __ ] 19 it's [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] utter [ __ ] so I got I was
lucky enough to get a good plane where I
got a good seat i sat next to the guy
who by the way if it wasn't the guy next
to me was the guy behind me or the guy
in front of me was lighting it up dude
he farted every every 40 minutes and I
would just have to [ __ ] duck into my
sweater and I mean dude this guy was
lighting it up I'm not even trying to be
funny he was lighting it up I couldn't
even believe it dude um and I was trying
to sit there eating my stuffed pepper
[ __ ] you with your stuffed pepper
they'll do that they'll get cute with
what they'll be like for your choice of
food is either chicken um or an ahi tuna
salad or we have a pepto-bismol shrimp
and you're like up up you know you're a
[ __ ] airplane why don't you cut the
funding for the pepto bismal shrimp and
get a [ __ ] place where you can hold
this goddamn chicken I have to hold dude
I'm talking about hey [ __ ] make put
the money into the goddamn reclining on
the seats a [ __ ] [ __ ] so so now
I'm on this plane I got a good one it
was probably made in like not you know
2009 or something and it's got all the
categories of the movies I could watch
it'll be like it's funny though they
tried it they try to make it they all
sort of make it better than
they do they'll be like new release it
you want to watch new releases and you
go and the new releases will be like
Dreamgirls the movie with [ __ ] Eddie
Murphy from 2005 you're like new
releases but no they did they had some
new releases and I was like um so I
picked inferno
that's a flight movie if I've ever heard
of one that's a flight move that's a
movie you watch on a plane the Tom Hanks
third installment to the [ __ ] da
Vinci called code third installment
Inferno with Tom Hanks and whoever liked
the new hot young sexy actresses that's
what that movie is like there's no like
if you have a movie with Tom Hanks
trying to find out [ __ ] riddles and
solve clues you don't you don't get if
you by the way its Felicity Jones whose
was beautiful she's great I thought she
was really good she's in a bunch of [ __ ]
I'm not trying to like I think she's a
great actress and she's beautiful but
like that's so who is gonna play that
role like there's no they got a British
or whoever wherever she's from she's not
American there's no [ __ ] way they'd
get an American for that there's no way
in hell some some producer was like what
what about and they said an American
girl and they literally shot him in the
[ __ ] head dolled up and it was legal
and they had a court hearing about and
they were like well he did mention you
know there is a law you can shoot the
producer if he does mention to hire an
American actress on the third
installment of The Da Vinci Code movie
when you already have Tom Hanks running
around [ __ ] Istanbul um so it's so
obvious that they had to pick a [ __ ]
the Felicity Jones just the metrics and
the whole system that's how it came okay
they came to be so they got her and they
and they and they got him I'm gonna fix
this microphone hold on so I gotta sit
differently so uh they they got this and
I turned it on and it sounds like oh
that's the movie you watch that's the
flight movie so I turned it on and I saw
the vinci code which was fine I read the
book which was awesome I don't give a
[ __ ] it was a pulp read but it was
awesome
and then I watched then I didn't watch
Angels & Demons because I I don't need
to see that again
you know I'm sure it was cool or
whatever but then I and it was a plane I
was on a plane I got let's watch
know so I watched the movie and and it
was I think Tom Hanks is I mean he's so
[ __ ] good I can't even like wrap my
head around it
I thought it was great in the movie with
the captain what's it called the captain
movie Captain Jones or captain okay
no no Sully was the the airplane one the
captain the one where he got you know
what I'm talking about captain's where
the guys took over the boat anyway
captain Phillips and he uh he was [ __ ]
amazing I mean that last scene of him
where he's like in shock and he's just
like III was like oh he's the best he
she he's unbelievable and but but but
that wasn't what made me think he might
be the greatest actor of all time what
made me think he might be the greatest
greatest actor of all time was when I
watched Sully which was he played a well
I don't know who how Sully is in real
life but he lived he legitimately played
the most boring character in the world
but made it so interesting I mean he
played a boring guy let's face it a
islet who's like sixty with a moustache
is boring I know that's a sweeping
generalization but show me the guy
that's a pilot with a moustache
that's just like some white guy that's
not boring I I'm being prejudiced a
hundred percent but he played this guy
and he played a boring guy I don't know
if the real Sully's boring but like it
was so good he was so good that he
played this guy and [ __ ] killed it I
mean the movie was fine it was good it
was good and he was great um and I was
like this guy's on another level to play
a boring ass [ __ ] and kill it
you know um so I watched inferno and oh
my oh my I mean this movie I don't even
know I don't even know maybe I'm a dumb
[ __ ]
but I didn't know what the [ __ ] these
clues that they left they might have
been speaking another language I didn't
know what the [ __ ] they were talking
about and this this movie did the two
things that I that I hate their devices
that I hate they're so overused and I
hate them the most the one I hate them
the most I'll say first which is the
character like something loud happens
while the characters doing something
like a train goes by and then it [ __ ]
he has like a violent flashback because
of it where he has to like kneel down
and then he remembers like and you get
like an image like a train goes by six
feet and then he's like I need to kind
of like kneels or grabs a table and then
we see like an image of like a hooded
guy in a field and we're like low as it
was at and then it goes back and he's
like grabbing the table and he's like ah
and then we find out the [ __ ] who the
hooded guy is later on in the movie
drives me nuts what why do you need a
train to go by to have the guy have a
flashback just have a [ __ ] flashback
what the [ __ ] that there was a birdie
to go ah any like look ha and then like
you see like a him as a kid and the moms
pouring him some some water and and and
and like she's like not drink it now
drink it and then later on you find out
that it was like poisoning him or some
[ __ ]
why you need a bird to call out I have
that [ __ ] happen just have the [ __ ]
flashback or I don't I don't like that
that drives me nuts here's the other one
here's the other one that I don't like a
guy who sees something and then and then
wipes his eyes and it's like hi and
looks and it's not there that drives me
nuts and this movie had both of those
things don't that drives me nuts I I
don't I don't even really want to
explain him more just like come on
movies how many movies are doing that
[ __ ] worries is like what the [ __ ] did
they see a guy and a snake comes out of
his back and then bites him on the neck
and he's like whoa and he looks and the
guy's not there and he's just at home in
his study he's like I better keep
googling this [ __ ] to find out the
bottom
I don't like that but the movie was just
uh it wasn't for me man
that being said I would have [ __ ]
killed a family member to be in that
movie that would've been awesome to be
in a [ __ ] inferno with Tom Hanks and
running around [ __ ] that I'll put on a
wig and be Felicity Jones Tom Hanks is
awesome dude you know was good in that
movie was that that guy in life up high
that 60 year old fear whatever the hell
his name is
really good that guy was [ __ ] awesome
um anyway I saw that then I turned on
Bourne Identity and it was like I'm
watching too many guys have flashbacks
they had the Bourne Supremacy or
whatever the [ __ ] the last one was born
optimum born ultra it took place in
Miami during the festival born you know
it was born book called born undeniable
and he had to [ __ ] go find out Joe
Buck you had to go find Joe Buck it were
he would have a flashback and then Joe
Buck would be interviewing Matt Damon
and Matt Damon was crying and then he
found him at the end and [ __ ] killed
Joe Buck and then everyone else everyone
who [ __ ] voted for the popular vote
was so happy um so yeah I watched that
and I got only half way through it and
then the plane landed I didn't know I
don't I don't know about dude I don't
I'm a I think I'm really dumb dude I
don't get movies man you got to explain
the [ __ ] to me so hard the movies gotta
be just about some basic [ __ ] it
literally has to be about a guy it had
the movie has to be called sitting down
and it has to be about a guy who just
like takes a seat and then has a
relationship with a girl that's totally
straightforward and then that's it no
flashbacks the second there's a
flashback I'm lost I'm like who was that
guy was that him was that his mom who
was the girl that brought him the water
I'm gone I'm gone I'm a [ __ ] idiot um
so I watched both of those and I love
Matt dam I look by the way there's a
scene in the [ __ ] Bourne Ultimatum
where Matt Damon just goes I love he
punches the [ __ ] it's the first scene
where he has to fight this guy and he
just walked right up to him and punches
him every dude loves that scene
like a [ __ ] yeah I would I would do that
but it would not be that way um yeah so
that's it about to born undeniable and
then and then that's it and then so
that's what I watched and I got home oh
you know what else I was thinking about
which is hilarious to me is that I saw
this picture oh oh by the way you know
what I'm [ __ ] sick of is uh when I
had this I had this I posted this thing
let me talk about this actually is I
wanted to talk about this I posted this
thing on Instagram let me pull it up it
was a sometimes if you know if you
follow me on Instagram you know my [ __ ]
I do these rants these long [ __ ]
rants that on making fun of these
pictures it usually has to do with
fashion or a couple being like -
annoyingly cute um and and I'll be like
hey make fun I'll make fun of the hey
guy don't wear this [ __ ] a hat it's
like a hat with like [ __ ] four bills
or something and a tail and I'll I'll
tag it congratulations world and if I do
it I do it all the time all the time and
I did this one you can go back and look
it was it was a week ago or some two
weeks ago Anna and I ended these people
driving with holding their guns and they
have these watches on that are like
these fancy watches and these these
Starbucks collar these coffees and if
the pictures so douchey it's just so
funny like and they got these fancy
watches on and they got the guns and
just they posed to take the picture it
just looks douchey and I made fun of it
I did one of those rants where I was
like oh it's so funny these guys will
shoot you fashionably not only will they
kill you I'll Drive I'll Drive by your
place after stopping at Starbucks and
shoot you with my girlfriend like you
know dumb [ __ ] but
I thought it was funny this guy who I
don't even I don't know his name or
whatever but he's got a bunch of
followers on Instagram I think his
name's Colin or so I don't know but uh
he like reposted he was like he's a he
was like this is not funny
gun rights you know and I looked at his
page and I was like this [ __ ] guy
like every other post was him shooting a
gun which is fine and I wasn't making
fun of I wasn't even saying don't have a
gun I was literally let me tell you
something if they didn't have these
watches on in this photo I wouldn't I
wouldn't have [ __ ] made front of the
photo it wouldn't been funny with that
if they were just holding the guns and
nothing it literally had nothing to do
with them having a guys it was just
making a joke and I was ranting and
these [ __ ] gun rights people dude I
mean it was amazing they lit me up on
his page and and dude I don't even give
a [ __ ] that much about that like about
the [ __ ] like hat I don't give a [ __ ] I
just thought it was a douchey photo like
these guys had to take the photos like
imagine these people take the photo Oh
baby put your gun right here put your
gun right here and make sure you show
your watch and I'm gonna try and snap
this photo of the both of us here like
this that's [ __ ] stupid I don't care
about your gun yeah an idiot um and then
they loaded it and then apparently this
guy was like this was a movement that
people were trying to do that were like
gun activists that were saying like you
know this hashtag they were trying to
make it some say like oh you don't know
the movement which is called steel
waiting
oh that's very dumb oh that makes it
worse though about how guns don't kill
people it's it's the people that do it
that are mentally unstable that do it
and and we're saying like we're still
waiting for the for the guns to go off
because I'm I'm a gun owner and I don't
know how to you know and I didn't I'm a
gun owner and I would never use it
irresponsibly which I get which okay
cool but don't call it steel waiting
because that's very very stupid steel
waiting dude oh you try to make it
better but you have a [ __ ] dorky pun
or whatever the [ __ ] you call it plan
words
by I get it man I get it I get it
nobody thinks a gun can kill somebody if
the gun isn't held by someone oh I get
it
have your gun do it do target practice
protect yourself but if I'm making fun
of a picture that's douchey that has
guns in it and you take it seriously
guess what
you're a [ __ ] problem you dummy um
yeah you're also getting mad at the
wrong guy dude you're getting mad at the
wrong guy I'll make fun of anything I
make fun of a guy with a [ __ ] hat on
I'll make fun of a guy with an oversized
coat on and a hat on we don't have
people saying hashtag and hats of
America like not cool dude because they
know it was a joke um yeah that was
crazy though man I kind of love it
though I love it
because these guys just [ __ ] they go
nuts man and then I'm like it makes me
giggle dude it makes me giggle in my
hotel room in Indianapolis yeah it's
just too much man this internet shinmin
dissenters internet ship uh I'm bi oh
and then then what blew up on Instagram
was Beyonce's photo beyonce does [ __ ] I
swear to god man Beyonce's the woman
without like that the strong woman you
know that like doesn't stand for [ __ ]
doesn't need a man get it we get it
she's her own woman she's amazing so
empowering to women and her own brand
and a phenomenal singer I mean let's
stand up grape just she's great uh but
it's so funny that Beyonce will take a
picture on top of a [ __ ] beat-up old
like
Ford or whatever the [ __ ] and pregnant
and naked and holding her titties and
people will be like go yay
and then if like a girl popular on
Instagram did that with 700,000
followers people would be like
slut-shaming her
that's hilarious to me you want there
people are who you want them to be in
your mind they're not who they are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I mean
people will look at Beyonce and be like
you go yay you don't need anybody to
tell you you can't do that [ __ ]
Oh BAE right BAE not yeah yes Kanye uh
whatever you go BAE Yonsei you go Yount
say hey use the whole name some people
call her BAE and some people call her
Yonsei just put it together [ __ ] and
say Beyonce and also dude but yeah
that's that that drives me crazy that
people are just who you want them to be
because you made it up in your head you
would take a [ __ ] girl who posts ass
hole shots literally or I saw a girl on
Instagram once post her a picture of her
in tights in this chain link fence and
the holes in the chain-link fence were
bigger than normal and she sat up
against the chain-link fence and and had
it so one of the links in the chain
links were in was in her ass crack and
her butt cheeks were coming out inside
though through the holes of the
chain-link fence and and I guess some
guys are like wow that's hot and then
some girls were like what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
all I could think all it was when I saw
that picture is how much actual [ __ ] now
is are on her pants because of the
chain-link pen vent pushing it in her
[ __ ] and if Beyonce did that people
will be like you go Yonsei you don't
need no man
you leave your man if you wanna go ahead
and smash a fire hydrant
go ahead Yonsei get that [ __ ] in that
neon in those neon tights like come on
dude come on no you don't get to [ __ ]
make up who people are in your own head
you got a [ __ ] god it drives me nuts
man
also whoo look she's amazing she figured
life out apparently and I you know I
actually think she's [ __ ] super
talented but who the [ __ ] takes a
picture on a car with like a veil over
her head and like holding her titties to
send out to Instagram to be like hey
guys I'm pregnant he's he'll that's in
that's that's wild dude that's like a
dream you would have and you'd wake up
and you be like dude I had this [ __ ]
crazy dream were like Yonsei was sitting
on the [ __ ] old broken-down Chevelle
with a bunch of flowers around her and a
veil over her face and body and holding
her titties and she was pregnant also I
love that I love that like so many women
left probably like left there man
after Beyonce came out with that song
where jay-z cheated on her and like it
literally probably inspired thousands of
women to leave their men and because
like him I don't need this guy anymore
he cheats on me and then and then
Beyonce was like stayed with her man and
and not only that is pregnant and not
only that is pregnant with twins jay-z
was like here you ain't going nowhere he
is - uh-uh
and like I had an orgasm in her [ __ ]
and was like there's - you ain't going
nowhere
yeah and then probably
left it was I gotta go work and they
made a song about [ __ ] that's the
best dude and then and then and then
Beyonce goes up and man is like [ __ ]
I'm announcing I'm pregnant
imma hold my titties and everyone's like
you go yawn say what is such a weird
world we live in man by the way I think
she should do that if she wants to I
think she should [ __ ] do that she
wants to the girl can [ __ ] put the
her [ __ ] up against the chain-link
fence if she wants to I don't give a
[ __ ] but like just shut the [ __ ] up
about it
shut the [ __ ] up about one thing's good
and the other things bad just because
it's a different person or maybe that's
right dude
maybe that's right maybe you build up
enough clout in the social media world
or in your [ __ ] personal world where
you can do a shot like that and it's
okay maybe the right maybe you're right
maybe I have no idea what I'm talking
about you know I don't know actually now
that I think about it maybe that is how
it should be on oh [ __ ] but yeah so
that's about it well we covered a lot of
[ __ ] no it's 50 minutes about so I think
that that's that might be good for
episode 2 or or whatever episode this is
talked about the Patriots winning
Atlanta I wanted to land out a win
though because I'm going to go I like
Atlanta I go there a lot to perform yeah
next week
when's this one going to come out okay
cool so yeah I'll be there I'll be there
in Atlanta maybe when this comes out but
um so yeah February 10th I think I'm in
Atlanta and then so yeah go I think it's
sold out I'm doing two shows but you can
check Chris D'Elia calm for that I got a
bunch of tour dates rolling up I got a
Raleigh rally I think I said rally last
time I don't think that's right I think
it's Raleigh North Carolina and then
Raleigh and Virginia Beach
Beecher and also a bunch of other ones
Australia and Vancouver and the Cooper's
weren't shoot my special Vancouver's
wrong shoot my special
I think that's might be sold out maybe
maybe there's tickets left on the second
showing I'm shooting both of those
though people always say oh you
shouldn't early winter the later on both
of them both of them and then Seattle I
think that might be sold oh I don't know
whatever but go check and tweet me
hashtag congratulations pod if you got
some questions or that maybe I can talk
you know if you wanted me to talk about
something if I get enough a certain of a
certain thing I might bring it up on the
next podcast so this has been episode 2
this one was 48 minutes 49 minutes and
we're going to get it you know this is
still the beginning but and then next
time I do this I do a show here doing
next episode will be less echoey I'm
sorry about the echo but I got [ __ ]
so many egg crate [ __ ] sound things
coming it's going to be insane and if
that doesn't work I'm just going to get
all my fat dude friends to come stand in
here while I talk and be and to have
them be quiet so all the sound will just
[ __ ] absorb in their [ __ ] fat
bellies so lost the whole audience right
there at the end and so and there and
then there's that and then I got some la
dates to everyone's always asking me
when I'm there tweeting me don't tweet
me if I'm in LM always in LA I don't put
those dates on my website just go to the
Comedy Store calm or the Laugh Factory
calm sometimes I'm at the improv calm so
that's that and then I guess that's it I
got a an episode coming out on the Great
Indoors with Joel McHale I played his
rival in an episode of that coming out
and
uh so be on the lookout for that's on
CBS that was a lot of fun and my new
specials coming out in this summer this
summer my new specials coming out and
then another movie coming out this
summer on Netflix called the little evil
so that's about it man thanks for
listening this is congratulations with
Chris D'Elia you guys are the best and
tweet me and use that hashtag
congratulations pot thanks a lot guys
[Music]